la storia che oggi siamo venuti a
raccontarvi a condividere con voi
inizia con un abbraccio l'abbraccio del
porto di messina che con quella sua
forma particolare sembra accogliere da
millenni tutte le persone che per
diversi motivi
arrivano in viaggio per mesi e mesi e
mesi
li abbiamo visti arrivare li abbiamo
visti arrivare sotto i nostri uffici
quelli dell'autorità di sistema portuale
dove io da più di 15 anni lavoro abbiamo
visto arrivare i migranti arrivavano
sulle navi militari sulle navi della
guardia costiera sulle navi delle
organizzazioni non governative e
arrivavano stravolti arrivavano stanchi
colpiti dal freddo dalla fame però
arrivavano spesso molto spesso con una
luce particolare negli occhi con a volte
un bel sorriso quello delle persone che
avevano capito che ormai il peggio era
passato era alle spalle e che adesso si
trovavano in un porto sicuro pronti a
ricominciare
e tutto questo ovviamente ci colpiva ci
colpì ma come un pugno nello stomaco
perché noi eravamo nel nostro ufficio
confortati nel totale sicurezza
e cosa ci colpiva ancor di più era che
contemporaneamente molto spesso
all'arrivo delle navi dei migranti
arrivavano nella banchina accanto delle
navi da crociera queste mega navi
bianche simbolo di lusso di sfarzo di
gioia di allegria e arrivavano accanto a
questa umanità a densa dolente però
forte pronta per ricominciare e come ben
potete immaginare noi eravamo i
testimoni i primi testimoni delle due
diverse motivazioni di viaggio
il viaggio per il divertimento e il
viaggio per la sopravvivenza e molto
spesso c'era anche una colonna sonora
molto particolare che anche questa
ovviamente contrastante da un lato la
musica del divertimento della discoteca
no delle navi da crociera e dall'altro i
canti africani i canti africani di chi
stava arrivando
e il tutto copriva le voci di chi sulle
banchine organizzava la loro accoglienza
messina varietà valera palestina boss
tyrone airest da un'idea di quasi 1
l'idea è venuta fuori durante una
chiacchierata una chiacchierata con una
mia amica speciale maria con la quale
spesso ci troviamo a confrontarci e
durante una di queste nostre belle
chiacchierate ci siamo chiesti è il
momento di rivoluzionare uno stereotipo
uno stereotipo che vede i migranti come
si a volte una risorsa ma come una
risorsa legata soprattutto alla loro
forza fisica e quindi li vediamo
impegnati in lavori che appunto
sfruttano la loro forza fisica nei campi
nei lavori edili o comunque qualcosa
legata a questo e io e maria non non
eravamo d'accordo non eravamo d'accordo
perché sapevamo che eravamo ben
consapevoli che i migranti sono persone
hanno sensibilità hanno intelligenza
hanno potenzialità culturali
i migranti sono nomi e non sono numeri
e allora ci siamo chieste io e maria
perché non immaginiamo un progetto che
faccia una rivoluzione dello stereotipo
perché non dar modo loro di mostrare
quali sono le loro potenzialità
culturali perché per esempio non provare
qualcosa provare ad impegnarli
nell'accoglienza turistica
per far questo è stato necessario
mettere su una rete una rete di enti
pubblici per cui l'autorità di sistema
portuale ha chiesto collaborazione in
questa rete al comune e alla città
metropolitana di messina perché sono
loro che gestiscono il punto informativo
turistico al terminal crociere e la rete
si è arricchita dalla presenza di una
scuola l'istituto tecnico jaci e poi ha
avuto la collaborazione indispensabile
di mehdi hospes cooperativa sociale
onlus che è quella che gestisce messina
le case di accoglienza dei minori
stranieri non accompagnati dei migranti
non accompagnati minori sono queste
strutture di accoglienza si chiamano
casa si chiamano casa med si chiamano
casa tour e si chiamano casa michelle e
quindi nasce il progetto che cos'è
questo progetto i migranti minori che
sono arrivati sbarcati nel porto di
messina ed a messina nel porto sono
stati accolti tornano nello stesso porto
torna ma sulle stesse banchine e tornano
ad accogliere altri viaggiatori i
crocieristi li accolgono nel terminal
crociere e li accolgono sfruttando le
loro potenzialità culturali che sono la
conoscenza ottima fluente dell'inglese e
del francese loro la conoscono molto
bene perché la lingua ufficiale dei loro
paesi di origine
tornano è però prima di tornare di
presentare la loro nuova città la loro
nuova casa che li ha accolti e quindi
messi
sono stati formati ulteriormente e poi
sono andati a passeggio fianco a fianco
con i loro coetanei i coetani della
scuola ajax uguali in mano per mano li
hanno portati da ciceroni a visitare la
città a fargli vedere i monumenti le vie
le strade i principali punti di
interesse turistico e camminando fianco
a fianco aiutandosi parlandosi si sono
conosciuti e conoscendosi si sono capiti
un po di più
anzi probabilmente molte di più e questo
è il progetto accoglimento my love boat
bar e tamara bit.ly mai grant turbato da
bot ha semmai grande cui sposo webcam in
the water stringa a quale ma la mia mai
ps to stadion di scovare city of messina
iwork surya squeeze eliana bot
difende monuments and museums and he
vero dianese suisse chiuso freddo sur
lie to be the city that a quelli mass
mandarmi tuca 53 dell'hawk eye on people
who like me anywhere staring out big da
racing su the passenger state drive
cruise terminal
it was great place to work side by side
with the stars la città metropolitana
course di bilic in as 7 bmbf sopporta
strade processo potete immaginare quante
emozioni ci ha regalato il progetto
accoglimento e ovviamente l'emozione più
grande è stata quando i nostri ragazzi
sono tornati sono anzi arrivati dietro
il bancone del punto informativo del
terminal crociere
mi corre l'obbligo e ci tengo
particolarmente
a ringraziare per le emozioni che ci ha
dato i dipendenti della città
metropolitana che hanno preso in
affidamento i ragazzi li hanno
affiancati li hanno seguiti e li hanno
curati in questa in questa loro
esperienza con un affetto veramente
straordinario
ma l'emozione più grande come vi dicevo
è stata quella quando loro hanno
cominciato a dare a svolgere loro la
loro funzione quindi hanno cominciato ad
accogliere i crocieristi e la cosa che
ci ha colpito di più oltre alla loro
bravura e che i crocieristi si
avvicinavano con un grandissima
naturalezza si fidavano dei loro
consigli delle loro indicazioni facevano
domande erano molto divertiti anche da
questa interazione e come vi dicevo
quello che ci ha colpito è stata la
naturalezza perché i crocieristi dietro
il bancone dell'infopoint vedevano dei
ragazzi di messina che accoglievano
nella loro città naturalezza dovuta
probabilmente anche al fatto che nei
paesi di origine dei crocieristi le
persone di colore occupano serenamente
lo stesso gli stessi ruoli ecco nel
nella piramide sociale la stessa
naturalezza vero non sempre l'abbiamo
vista negli occhi dai crocieristi
italiani tanto a coleman è che un
batterio porta simonov a come una di
sempre
number one saving tifo iamm cannes sono
fuori dalle genti jeans di tool castrum
suo confidente e stringe le mani ago 09
in tasca
stringer ho detto giustamente to go sud
e siti senta del suo appeal e riess the
beaches tauran e migliorati in studio
city map waka mille stringa into the
city and the great escape di khost è tua
verremo fuori tu sai mai se camminano
per sen
come vi dicevo prima potete immaginare
quante emozioni ci ha regalato il
progetto accoglimento e quante cose ci
ha insegnato le più importanti
adesso voglio condividerle con voi la
prima è che rivoluzionare gli stereotipi
e scommettere sulle capacità delle
persone è sempre molto meglio
la seconda è che gli enti pubblici
se imparano a fare rete sono sicuramente
in grado di sviluppare progetti molto
più efficaci a costo zero perché
accoglie me è stato un progetto a costo
zero quindi molto più efficaci e
innovativi di quelli che si potrebbero
sviluppare seguendo le strade della
tradizionale sterile burocrazia
la terza è che l'integrazione di persone
e delle loro potenzialità culturali
funziona molto più della ghettizzazione
la quarta è che chi oggi ha bisogno di
aiuto domani sfruttando le sue capacità
può essere sicuramente di aiuto agli
altri e la l'ultima ma forse la più
importante quella che ci porteremo
sempre nel cuore e che accoglie me ci ha
insegnato che abbracciare e molto meglio
di respingere e last but not the least
trova quelli mai a guerre
amo sei bellissima allora di sindaci si
chiamava vaccinare infopoint mostrava
fumi batte city a nevaio immagini ma la
q2 ammessi bellissima
[Applauso]